Tonight, when the sun goes down, you're
going to flip a switch. Light will flood
the room, and you won't think twice
about it. But for 99.9%
of human history, that switch didn't
exist. When the sun set, the world went
dark. You couldn't even see your own
hand in front of your face. But modern
humans almost never experience this. For
over 300,000 years, every single one of
your ancestors spent roughly half their
life in near total darkness. They didn't
even have candles for most of that time,
just the black sky, the stars, and
whatever fire they could keep alive. So,
what did they actually do for all those
hours? The answer changes everything we
think we know about sleep, storytelling,
and what it means to be human. Let's
start with fire, because fire is the
reason any of this was possible. The
earliest solid evidence of humans
controlling fire comes from Wonderwerk
Cave in South Africa, roughly 1 million
years ago. But fire didn't just keep
people warm. Fire completely
restructured the human day. Before fire,
our ancestors were like every other
primate. When the sun went down, you
climbed a tree or found a sheltered
spot, and you stayed still. Moving at
night meant becoming food. Our eyes are
terrible in the dark compared to the
predators that hunted us. Leopards,
hyenas, wolves, all of them could see
just fine. Fire changed that equation
overnight, literally. A campfire creates
a circle of safety roughly 30 ft in
diameter. Inside that circle, predators
won't come. Outside that circle, you
die. This is not an exaggeration.
Anthropologists studying modern
hunter-gatherer groups have documented
that people who wander away from the
fire at night are significantly more
likely to be killed by predators, even
today. But here's what's fascinating.
Fire didn't just protect humans at
night. It gave them something they'd
never had before, extra hours. Think
about this. Before fire, the useful day
ended at sunset. That's maybe 12 hours
in summer, as few as eight in winter.
Fire suddenly added two to four usable
hours to every single day. And over
thousands of generations, those extra
hours changed our species. In 2014,
anthropologist Polly Wiessner published
a study in the Proceedings of the
National Academy of Sciences. She spent
years recording conversations among the
Ju/’hoansi Bushmen of the Kalahari
Desert, one of the last groups on Earth
still living something close to the
original human lifestyle. What she found
was striking. During the day, about 80%
of conversations were practical. Who's
hunting where? Which plants are ready?
Complaints, logistics, economic
negotiations. Daytime talk was work. But
at night, around the fire, the entire
character of conversation changed. 81%
of conversations were stories, tales of
people in distant places, adventures,
myths about the origins of the world,
jokes that made the whole camp laugh.
Wiessner argued that firelight
conversation is where human culture was
born. The campfire was the original
theater, the original classroom, the
original church. It's where humans
learned to think beyond the immediate
present and imagine things that don't
exist yet. It's where we became us. But
the night wasn't just about stories
around the fire. There was something
else happening, something that
scientists only rediscovered in the last
30 years. You were not designed to sleep
the way you sleep right now. In 2001,
historian Roger E. Ekirch published a
paper that changed sleep science. He had
spent 16 years digging through
historical records, and he found
something nobody expected, over 500
references spanning centuries, prayer
books from the 1400s, court records,
diaries, medical texts, letters from
ordinary people, even passages in
Homer's Odyssey. All of them mentioned
the same thing, first sleep and second
sleep. Before the industrial age, people
did not sleep in one continuous block.
They went to bed shortly after sunset,
slept for about 4 hours, then woke up.
They stayed awake for 1 to 2 hours in
the middle of the night. Then they went
back to sleep for another 4 hours until
dawn. This wasn't insomnia. This was
normal. This was how every human on the
planet slept for thousands of years. And
what did people do during that wakeful
period in the middle of the night?
Everything. A 16th-century French
physician recommended that couples
conceive children during this window,
because they would do it better. People
visited neighbors. They interpreted
their dreams while they were still
fresh. They wrote. They simply lay in
bed in the dark and thought. A doctor's
manual from the 1500s advised patients
that the best time to study and reflect
was during the watch, as they called it,
the quiet hours between first and second
sleep, when the mind was calm and the
world was still. Now, historians had
been reading these references for
centuries, but they kept translating
first sleep as something else, because
they couldn't imagine that people ever
slept differently than we do now. The
assumption was so deep that translators
literally mistranslated ancient Greek
and medieval Latin to make it fit their
modern experience. But then science
confirmed what history had been saying
all along. In 1992, psychiatrist Thomas
Wehr at the National Institute of Mental
Health ran an experiment. He took a
group of volunteers and removed all
artificial light from their lives. For 1
month, they experienced 14 hours of
darkness every night, just like our
ancestors would have before fire
extended the evening. Within weeks,
every single participant settled into
the same pattern, 4 hours of sleep, 1 to
3 hours of quiet wakefulness, then 4
more hours of sleep. Nobody told them to
do this. Nobody suggested it. Their
bodies just did it, as if some ancient
program had been waiting inside them the
whole time, buried under centuries of
artificial light. Wehr measured their
hormone levels during the wakeful period
and found something remarkable. The
participants were in a state unlike any
normal waking state. Their brains were
producing elevated levels of prolactin,
the same hormone released during
meditation and after orgasm. They
described feeling peaceful, reflective,
almost meditative. It wasn't just a gap
in sleep, it was its own distinct state
of consciousness, one that most modern
humans have never experienced. So, what
killed it? The answer is simpler than
you'd think, light. In the 1600s, cities
began installing street lamps. Paris was
one of the first under Louis XIV, who
wanted to reduce crime. London followed.
The night, which had been a place of
danger and fear, slowly became
navigable. Then came cheaper candles,
then gas lamps in the 1800s. Then, in
1879, Thomas Edison commercialized the
electric light bulb, and within a
generation, the night as humans had
known it for 300,000 years was gone. And
here's the part nobody talks about. The
word curfew comes from the French
couvre-feu. It literally means cover
fire. In medieval towns, a bell would
ring at night, signaling everyone to
cover or extinguish their fires, not
because of safety, because night was
supposed to be dark. Night was when you
slept. Night was when you were
vulnerable. For most of history, being
out at night was suspicious. In many
medieval European cities, walking
outside after dark without a lantern was
literally illegal. Night belonged to
criminals and the supernatural. People
feared it in a way that's almost
impossible for us to understand today.
And then we conquered it. We flooded it
with light, and we thought that was
progress. But here's what we lost.
Modern humans are exposed to artificial
light an average of 7 to 8 hours after
sunset. This light, especially the blue
light from screens, suppresses your
body's production of melatonin, the
hormone that regulates sleep. Your body
doesn't know the difference between a
light bulb and the sun. When light hits
your retina at 11:00 p.m., your brain
interprets it as daytime. It delays
melatonin release. It fragments your
sleep. It disrupts the circadian rhythm
that evolved over millions of years.
Researchers have found that people who
go camping for just 1 week with no
artificial light at all have their
melatonin cycles reset by nearly 2
hours. Their bodies start producing
melatonin at sunset instead of hours
after it. That's all it takes for
300,000 years of programming to reassert
itself. We didn't just change when we
sleep. We eliminated an entire phase of
human consciousness. That quiet,
reflective state between first and
second sleep, the state that Wehr's
subjects described as peaceful and
meditative, doesn't exist anymore for
most people. Instead, we have insomnia,
and we treat it like a disorder. But
what if it's not a disorder at all? What
if waking up at 2:00 a.m. and lying
there in the dark isn't your body
malfunctioning? What if it's your body
remembering what it was built to do? For
300,000 years, your ancestors spent
their nights in a rhythm that modern
science is only beginning to understand.
They gathered around fires and told
stories that built civilizations. They
slept in two phases with a window of
quiet reflection in between. They lived
in darkness so complete that the Milky
Way wasn't something you had to drive to
a national park to see. It was just the
sky. And every night when they woke in
the dark between first and second sleep,
they lay there in silence and thought
about their lives, their dreams, and the
world they would wake up to in the
morning. We traded all of that for a
light switch, and most of us never even
knew it was gone.